recognition and reward is still
important you know it doesn't always
have to be financial it can be um
public gratitude you know praise and
public criticize and private that whole
thing you know i just want to point out
you know thanks to you know
thanks to you know whoever for doing
something in in a large group that makes
people feel good especially when we're
recognizing rewarding integrity and
upholding values
i'm a huge fan of recognizing and
rewarding initiative
for example i'll give you a quick
example so when i was young in my career
i worked at a big ad agency and when we
have a new business pitch it was the the
senior folks who do the pitches
and
the junior kids are just assigned to
support
this new pitch was going to be the first
of the year the beginning of the year
and so
christmas vacations were there and all
the senior folks left for the vacation
and the junior kids were left back
because i didn't take a vacation and
they told us to prepare the war room
right which basically means hang the
research on the wall
right which took an hour
and we had a week to kill and so me and
this other junior kid we did the whole
pitch ourselves because we had a week to
kill and they came back all the senior
folks and we presented our strategy for
this pitch and they ended up using our
strategy
for the pitch and we lost the business
we lost the pitch we did not win and i
got a huge promotion they moved me two
levels up
and what my boss was rewarding was not
the outcome but it was my behavior
because you cannot incentivize
performance you can only incentivize
behavior right he understood that
sometimes good leaders suffer mission
failure and sometimes bad leaders enjoy
mission success so when we only reward
outcome we're missing the behavior
and so i got a huge huge promotion why
because he wants me to take more
initiative with the expectation that if
i take lots of initiative we're going to
win more pitches
and so i think striking the right
balance you
extrinsic is totally fine but the
question is what are we rewarding
are we just rewarding the person who
wrote the most tickets and made the most
arrests are we rewarding the people who
are solving problems and upholding our
values